Evolution is everywhere!
Everywhere!
All around you.
It's even happening right here
in this very studio, sort of.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Everyone, Laci
Green here for DNews
with a special
guest, Catie Wayne.
You may recognize Catie
from Animalist News
or from her own channels,
Boxxybabee and ANewHopeee.
Thanks for joining
me on DNews, lady.
Thanks for having me.
Of course.
So Miss Catie Wayne, do you know
what the most common argument
I hear against evolutionists?
What?
That there's no proof for
it because you can't see it.
But don't they know that it
takes hundreds of thousands
of millions of years to happen?
Apparently not.
But you know what's awesome?
Not all examples
of evolution happen
outside the course
of a human life.
There's some animals evolving
right before our very eyes.
Yeah!
Like wild elephants naturally
selecting to have no tusks.
It's pretty sad, actually.
In 25 years, the wild
elephant population
in both Asia and Africa has
been reduced to less than half
because of poachers.
Poachers have become
such a serious threat
to their existence that the rate
of elephants born without tusks
has shot through the roof.
In some parts of the world,
tusk-less elephants only
made up about 5%
of the population,
and now it's getting
close to a third.
So to be clear,
natural selection
is the driving force
behind evolution.
You may have heard of the
survival of the fittest?
It's a scientific
theory that animals
best suited to survive
pass their traits on.
So good traits for
survival become
more common in a species,
while bad traits, in this case
the tusks, become less common.
Their bad traits get them killed
or eaten, so they die off,
or perhaps none of
the animals want
to mate with them because
of those bad genes.
So basically, the tusks
are a greater threat
to the elephants'
survival than not
being able to dig
for food and water.
That's right.
You ready for another
depressing example?
No, but yes.
You're ready.
I know you're ready.
Before the Industrial
Revolution,
when Britain wasn't
polluted, pale moths
were able to rest
on the pale growths
on trees, which are called
lichen, to hide from the birds
and predators.
Fast forward after
the industrial boom,
and suddenly there's a
lot more smoke in the air,
killing the lichen growths
off and causing the tree
bark to darken.
Then the pale moths
became easy targets.
Meanwhile, the dark
moths were well hidden,
so they were able to
survive and reproduce.
And they eventually became
the most common moth color,
while the pale ones were rare.
Boom!
The moths had evolved.
Indeed.
And when Britain started
reducing its pollution levels,
the pale moth started
to flourish again.
Boom!
Evolving again.
But you know, one of my favorite
examples of evolution in action
is actually in humans.
Oh, really?
Humans are losing
their pinky toes.
Good, because I
really can't think
of a more useless
thing on my body.
Well, you know, Laci, they
weren't always so useless.
Our whole foot used to
look more like monkey feet,
meaning they used
to look like hands.
They were prehensile,
and we used
to climb trees and
stuff with them.
Now that we're bipedal and
stopped doing such things,
we don't really need
the fifth appendage.
We could easily get
by with just four.
We don't even use the pinky
toe for balance or anything.
Aren't wisdom teeth
kind of the same deal?
Yes.
That's why we get them removed,
because they're so stupid
and stuff.
And probably also
because our jaws
are getting a little smaller.
Our teeth no longer play a
vital role in our survival,
so they're getting selected out.
And because they're
so stupid and stuff.
And also that.
Thanks for joining
us for DNews, folks.
Be sure to check out
Catie on Animalist News
at youtube.com/animalist or at
animalist.com We'll catch you
next time.
Byee!
[MUSIC PLAYING]